merry Chris oh you're here Oh welcome my
senpai Merry Christmas Merry Christmas a
rewind what what are we gonna perfect oh
I found the best game I could possibly
find cuz Christmas is a special day we
need to play the best game possible I've
been saving this game for years Wow
literally 2012 is back cuz we're playing
slender man's shadow you can have the
option to play or run away what do you
choose play okay slender means shedding
yeah it could be an e oh my god
I think it's been oh just an e to me
that hey daddy you scared us to think of
that face he's like God check got him is
there anything christmas-related oh yeah
this is the Christmas special dan and
Phil played it and I did not rip this
idea from them but I haven't seen this
Adam watch them either collect all eight
Prancer do we move I don't know probably
WASD yeah there you go
I'll do the looking you do the walking
I like the music good choice of music
game alright let's go in here wow I am
so I'm so in festive Christmas mood
right now sorry we looking for the note
yeah now present eight presents
[Music]
hey there's a snowman
this music is amazing anyone hold up and
say oh but how sweet Mike to take it
over how dance what I'm walking oh you
can okay
how many gives seven eight we need eight
you got to go faster
okay I'm not finding any presents try
over here I already hate the music oh oh
we found it we found one got it
ah I think the bays in prudhoe Abed all
we did oh my god just try and focus on
the happy music Mart say we can do this
slant to cut slant
slanter is coming I don't know where to
go that's the problem
Oh oh it was [ __ ] down and it's not a
good thing where is he I'm not scared of
Santa this this isn't I hate this game
oh my god
[Music]
oh my god that was so scary
why there was not finished
I guess nine
I guess Danny are you trying to hit on
my girl Danny
yeah I'm hating her she makes my knees
weak oh I can't hit him I can't touch me
here let's see your whole day okay how
about I do we take turns how about that
okay how about I move with the mouse
okay
oh my god I'm having a seizure don't do
that please I felt a sec oh my god Annie
can you get off me
Danny get off my girl I want to die
please kill me
Merry Christmas to the bros we have to
beat this game we have to leave the
music is like that yes okay let's pick
it up stop sucesses
got it okay Brown got him all right keep
looking Oh go go go straight [ __ ] Oh got
him oh oh hey sanna sanna sanna was that
you Stan we're technically stealing
gifts I wouldn't now we take this our
gift it's our gift damn it oh my god
memory you were like like what's wrong
with you
you got spent scared by a scary scary
game I thought I would see how it was we
are so bad at this game
Hey what what are you doing with Danny I
made him stay straight fine
it was magnificus you just don't know
how to handle a man okay it's so creepy
in the bag look at that
he's right between us huh yeah do you
out of eight come on girl we can do this
wicked there's so many damn houses oh
that's a tiny little gift Oh
take it and go get out for recruit
[ __ ] crippled men we don't even
see him this game sucks
let's switch to another one what are you
doing right now
thank you this is Danny DeVito's arms
around me it looks like a Oh Danny Danny
nope
[Music]
this is the scariest her Christmas game
yeah on YouTube take a what is it is it
Krampus its I feel I feel we are getting
so close to this cream oh wow like
watching it professional that look at
that tree it looks so great what do I
have to do I don't know this looks awful
I mean Oh
I just happened
what is this game
this is so bad Santa Claus is coming my
dear checking it twice god oh god
we're dead were so dead mercy oh my god
is that Santa that looks like a troll
ten out of ten not to go oh my god yes
great yes it's one of those videos isn't
it you're right
are you ready mom ready are you ready
let's yeah oh my god I hate this dashing
through the snow and I wanna die
what if the snowman is actually Sampath
I go did you put it up we yeah oh oh
whoa oh my god is coming
sanika who gather what the [ __ ] yes Anna
hate you but do get me some presents
cuz I've been a very good boy oh yeah
okay you want me to do it don't take off
my clothes
you want the fangirls is that what you
thank you I'll show you how it's done
right it's it I'll do it for you then I
play without you okay fine
oh my god don't rub my nipple this is
weird this is we are you dancing in the
background I don't have time to look
there sir present right day yeah yeah
huh so why do we there's a present Thank
You Janet DeVito tell thing I don't like
the I mean what is that voice you gave
to any o3 see what happens when I don't
play with you I'm kidding I'm kidding
I'm game don't hurt no don't leave me I
need you Marty I'm kidding I need you it
was Danny that did it all alone for you
think you're so good huh I
oh my God he's coming Martin
so oh my gosh hey how's it going it's
Danny DeVito and Marcia you're doing so
good my sheesh what if I win this game
who else - similar yeah oh how do I pick
it up
what that's right wait you actually got
one by yourself
she shouldn't what did you think [ __ ]
let me stop trying to make me lose I'm
doing great without you Oh still doing
great yeah you're doing great you
feeling good I never see you good temp
scared so I think we have to end it
there
hey fine too much yeah there they
doesn't get better than that
all right thank you clap it up merry
merry Christmas to everyone we get a
shoe a sleepy one is this a Merry
Christmas
okay Merry Christmas from all of us and
sleepy wait sleepy wants to say Merry
Christmas and Happy New Year
Thank You myself for coming on and then
we're gonna be in Sweden for Christmas
celebrating Christmas so we hope you
enjoyed this video meanwhile there is no
snow I'm gonna be very disappointed but
yeah hope you're doing and as always
actually you know what we do now check
out this video
oh my God look at that video click on it
right now
you are on the video now you're there
you go clicking and we'll have fun and
click on that Wow